hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrolat.l2-3.2.2 ensure the
organizational Personnel are adequately
trained to carry out their assigned
information security related duties and
responsibilities
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so in
cmmccontrolat.l1-3.2.2 ensure that
organizational Personnel are adequately
trained to carry out their assigned
information security related job duties
and responsibilities
here again in this control it's all
about making sure that the people are
adequately trained but especially those
people who have information security
related job duties this Nuance is
critical as assessors will be looking to
information managers to see if they have
adequate training versus other employees
great example somebody doesn't have cui
uh you know in their possession they
don't need to be trained on some things
someone who's going to handle cui they
should get that mandatory dodc UI
trained just as a small example uh again
people who may not require higher levels
of information security training to
actually protect cui or not people that
you know may need the extra training so
let's check out what the assessors are
actually looking for on this one and
find out how to keep them happy so on
this compliance control there are three
places that they're going to be
assessing on so Point number one is
determine if information security
related duties roles and
responsibilities are defined
uh again just kind of throwing out a
sample answer here the organization
defines each authorized user's job
duties role and responsibilities in job
descriptions yes cmmc may want to look
you know a cmmc assessor may want to
look at a job description right because
we have to find out if that information
security related duty role or
responsibility is actually defined so
that that person knows that that's what
they're supposed to be doing sounds like
common sense but believe me if you ask
some people they have no idea that part
of their job duty is well to secure
information now Point number two
determine if information security
related duties roles and
responsibilities are assigned to
designated Personnel the organization
assigns so if I just give a sample
that's why I say the organization
assigns information security related
duties roles and responsibilities via
job roles and descriptions so again you
get the job description maybe there's a
signature line at the bottom of it
you're signing off that you're the one
doing that job and it's your
responsibility might be something to
think about okay if that's if that kind
of paper is not in your company now
might be really good to kind of ask
about that because again you're going to
have to give a clear demonstration of
this
now final point is determine if
Personnel are adequately trained to
carry out their assigned information
security related job duties and roles
and responsibilities so again this is a
little tricky because you got to make
sure if somebody goes through training
you have proof they went through that
training very important it's got to be
documented because you're gonna have to
prove it to an Assessor uh if we were to
give a sample answer we would say
Personnel are required to go through
adequate training or show proof of
certifications that's right we're
talking about certifications now or
previous training prior to gaining
access to that cui to carry out assigned
information security related job duties
roles and responsibility okay great
example is hey look if you've got an I.T
director maybe they got a Security Plus
certification again that just
demonstrates clearly that they've got
Advanced security training now there's
no minimum security or there's no
minimum certification or anything like
that but again those do count towards
justifying and evidence
now if all of this sounds very confusing
to you or you're struggling on the
policies or you're struggling with all
these gaps you may have or you just
don't even know where to begin here's
the good news and on call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had the dfars nist itar and cmmc
compliant stuff dropped in their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance as you see her
weapon along with my bad jokes to land
more Defense work with higher profit
margins that's what's becoming an
on-call compliance hero can do for you
if you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit
cmmccompliance secrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content I'm
putting out here for you help us out
with a big fat thumbs up on that like
button it really shows us the love and
even better smash that subscribe button
to get the latest compliance content as
soon as our compliance nerds roll it out
until the next compliance tip my friends
stay safe and secure out there and hit
us in the comments below to let us know
what you like like to know more about
when it comes to information security
and compliance I'll see you on the next
one
[Music]